eu tenho medo de andar de avião da eu
ando por necessidade mas eu tenho medo
eu quando eu vou comprar passagem de
algumas que dei uma passagem para o
Havaí você quer sentar aonde eu falei
tem como eu sentar na caixa preta do
avião
não só acha a caixa preta quando cai
o avião sumiu mas encontramos a caixa
preta no oceano aí em cima assim na
caixa preta assim eu vou sentar quero
ver eu morrer eu tenho medo eu falo a
verdade
eu não vou falar mentira para você aqui
e a pessoa que vende a passagem parece
que ela não quer que você boi quer te
botar medo assim me dê o número de
emergência
falei para quê
falou põe emergência falei Não é para
ter emergência nenhuma aqui
não mas em casa tinha emergência eu
tenho que ligar para alguém eu digo para
mim Pega o meu número então
vai ligar para minha mãe vai segurar o
avião não vai segurar